- Hello. Hey, everybody!
- I was like, how are you?
- Wow, well, I'm so good.
Thank you for having me back on.
- Yes, we love having you on!
I'm very excited.
I love this jacket, I might steal it.
- You can. I'll leave it
- Green is my favorite color.
- in the dressing room for you.
- Okay Thank you, thank you.
Um, have y'all met before?
- Oh, yeah.
- I feel like you've been
on a movie before
- We have met before.
She's actually been to
a party at my house.
- Wait, what? Oh (laughs)
- Yes. Yes.
- That's a different kind,
I thought you just worked together.
- What about Twin Peaks?
- Ah well, that was where we.
- Yes.
- first worked together.
Yeah It was Twin Peaks.
- Okay, okay.
- Oh, sorry yeah, that was my,
I was like, oh, I can die now.
- I can die now.
(laughter)
- I'm good, I'm solid.
Oh, wait, I saw that you
had an encounter though
with an alligator, and
I wanna talk about it
cause we were talking
about animals earlier.
- Yes, yes.
- I would never do this. Here we go.
- [MacLachlan] It looks more
dangerous than it actually is.
- [Kelly] Well, no, it
looks how I feel like it is.
- [Seyfried] No, it's pretty (inaudible)
(laughs)
- Yeah, I feel like it's super dangerous
and you know what they like to do,
they like to drown you.
- Yes, They grab you and their
jaw and they take you down.
- And then they eat you later.
- Yes.
- When you're tender, once you're tender.
- So, what were you doing?
- So we were out in the Everglades.
- Okay.
- We are a national parks family so,
we go to national parks.
- Oh, I love, me too.
- And we went out on one of the jet boats,
the air boats I think.
- Yeah, with a big fan on the back.
- Yes, yes
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And there's an area
out there where these,
there's two large ones kind of hang out.
But our guide has known
them since they were
a little tiny creatures so,
he feels quite comfortable.
So he was actually just to the left there,
and I was on an extreme zoom so,
objects were nearer than they appeared
if you know what I mean.
- Oh my God.
- So I was there watching this
alligator come and filming it
and he's right to my left.
I was not actually in the grass,
I was up on a little platform.
But my son, when he said,
does anybody want to touch the alligator?
He went down next to him,
and he actually put his hand out,
touched the snout,
scratched underneath his,
what you do in here?
- What
- And the gator was just totally
fine and very comfortable,
I was freaking out of course.
- Yeah.
- But he was fearless, my son had no fear.
He's 13 and fearless.
- [Kelly] Oh my God but see,
I feel like people get
fearless on vacations.
- I know
- You think you can't die!
- Was it a bad parenting moment?
Maybe it was bad
- I'm just saying,
I feel like you think you
can't die on vacations.
People do crazy things on vacations.
Yeah, I know! I would
never touch an alligator!
- I mean, have you seen TV shows?
- I (laughter)
- They're dangerous.
- No, that's a, they're
beautiful, they're awesome.
- They are. They're stunning,
and you do feel like
you've gone back in time,
I mean they are prehistoric.
- Prehistoric. Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God ,Yeah.
- Yeah, you've been here longer than us.
- Um, so you also did something
else that's very cool.
So you recently you opened the Prada show?
- Yes. That's what you do.
- So I mean, what, so how did that happen?
(applause)
How did that come about?
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- So, so
- [Kelly] Look at you!
- [Seyfried] Damn , damn, damn.
- I know.
- Look at that blue seal look, oh my gosh.
Look at him look at the camera.
Aye!
- There it is.
- I mean was that so fun?
- One thing that was
going through my head,
- What?
- don't fall down.
- Amen. (laughs)
- Do not trip, hat was
really my motivation.
Ralph Simons who's working
with Mrs. Prada, Miuccia Prada,
he's been there for two years now,
and he's always kind of liked my stuff,
Twin Peaks and the David Lynch stuff,
and he invited myself and
a number of other actors
including Jeff Goldblum,
- Yeah.
- Who's also in the show.
- Oh, I've worked with him he's fun. yeah
- He's lovely.
And so they said come to
Milan and do this and I said
it's really gonna happen
because of COVID and everything,
and it did happen, and they
took such good care of us,
they were so gracious , so kind.
- That's such a cool idea.
- It's so fun.
- Yeah.
- I mean just like just go
and have a good time in Milan.
- Yeah
- You know
- (inaudible) fine.
- Yeah, and after that, then you go out
and you eat pasta afterwards.
You don't eat pasta before:
you have to go out afterwards.
- Why I could never be a model,
(laughter)
one of the many reasons.
So wait, so that Prada
video was on your TikTok,
So how does your teenage son,
how does your 13 year old feel about that?
- Oh, he cringes, he cringes.
- Oh he did?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He didn't think at all, like that's rad?
- No my, anything I do
on TikTok, he's like,
Dad that's just not cool.
You know, I'm, you know,
I'm still old school
so I like TikTok to be
a little nice and kind
of planned out, you know?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And I think thing to do
is you just kind of do
- It's to be kind of like
- Spontaneous Right?.
- But they say it's spontaneous.
- You think it really is?
- It's not spontaneous.
- Not really, yeah
- You know how many times they did that
before they posted it? Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They be lying. Yeah, Yeah.
- All those people
they're like, oh no, wait
this angle was better.
- Yeah so (laughs)
- Okay, I feel better.
I feel better thanks Kelly.
- It's not you you're not
cringey, you're awesome.
- Thanks.
- Well Kyle's knew Peacock
show is Joe Versus Carole.
So did you, did y'all
watch the Tiger King?
Did you see it?
- Yes.
- For sure.
- Yeah, well.
- I saw like bits of it.
It was, it kind of scared me,
like humans scared me sometimes.
- I totally agree.
- Yeah.
They were scarier than
the animals I gotta say.
- Yeah, yeah
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. But it was, but
I had a lovely time.
So we shot down in Brisbane.
- Okay.
- there in Australia
for a couple of months.
Yeah, It's really beautiful down there.
And I worked with Kate McKinnon.
She plays Carole and she's extraordinary.
- Love her
- work with her she's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It was really fun.
We worked in a beautiful part of Brisbane,
and we were on set, mostly on set.
There were no tigers,
so it's a Tiger King,
no tigers, so they did everything after.
- Oh.
- CG, everything else.
- That's safe.
- So we had Great Danes walking around.
- Oh my gosh.
- In place.
Yeah, they were so cause
they're so elegant and graceful.
So we, those were, and
then they would just
they were gonna CG and the
CG and the tigers after that.
- Wow!
- We did have one house cat,
hat was unbelievable though.
Regular cat, the coolest
cat, I think I've ever seen.
And he would do anything!
He would come if he was,
he would come from there,
he would come through here,
he walk up, and he'd
just hop up next to you.
- And he was just like a part of the cast
or just like hang out?
- He was in for some of the scenes yeah
- Oh okay.
- Awesome, that was the
only animal that we used.
- I can't, yeah, it's
better than an alligator
I don't want be around that.
- Better than the alligator
- I love that, you were like,
you know, it was far away
cause I was on the camera.
But I'm like, if I can
capture, if I'm close enough
to capture an alligator,
I don't want to be there.
(laughs)
like Nope.
- Not a chance.
- Well it's I was
like not a thrill seeker.
Well, it's great to see you both again.
- Thank you.
(applause)
- Everybody watch Joe vs Carole on Peacock
and The Dropout on Hulu.